[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام انا طاهر بركي
احييكم وهذه العربيه 360 حيث الخبر من كل
زواياه ومن جميع جوانبه
وكاله الطاقه تؤكد رصد جزيئات يورانيوم
مخصب بنسبه تقارب 90% في ايران والاخيره
تتمسك بروايه الحادث العارض
رئيس وزراء اوكرانيا يؤكدوا للعربيه العمل
على محاسبه روسيا امام الجنائيه الدوليه
ويتهم ايران بمساعدتها
لضرب نفوذ روسيا في الخاصره اسيا الوسطى
يروج لجولته هناك بورقه الشريك الموثوق
وسيكون لدينا ايضا
في كارثه زلزال تركيا المعارضه تطالب
بمحاكم خاصه والعربيه ترصد من الجنوب
تداعي الاقتصاد بعد المباني
[موسيقى]
كشفت الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه عن
اكتشاف جزيئات يورانيوم مخصب في ايران تقل
نسبتها بقليل عن 90% وهي نسبه كافيه لصنع
سلاح النوويه وقالت الوكاله ان ايران
ارجعت هذه النسبه الى امكانيه حدوث خلل في
عمليه التحصيب الا ان الوكاله انتقدت
ايران لعدم الشفافيه في السماح بمراقبه
منشاتها النوويه وكاله الطاقه الذريه اكدت
ان مخزون ايران من اليورانيوم المخصب بنسب
مختلفه زاد بنحو 87 كلغ منذ اخر تقرير
فصلي ليصل الى اكثر من
3760 كيلو جراما وافادت الوكاله ان هذا
المخزون يتجاوز السقف المسموح به لايران
باكثر من ثمانيه عشره مره كما اضافت
الوكاله ان ايران لديها 42 كلغ من
اليورانيوم المخصب بنسبه 60% وهو يحتاج
لتعزيز بسيط لانتاج سلاح نووي
معنا من لندن البحث في الشان الايراني
عارف نصر اهلا بك معنا استاذ عارف
مره جديده حديث عن تخصيب باقل من 90
بالمئه فهل تعتقد بانه الموضوع سيبقى قيد
التداول
وستتمكن الوكاله ربما مع الغرب من نفي
الروايه التي تتمسك بها طهران وهي الحادث
العارض
تحيه طيبه لك استاذ طاهر والمشاهده
العربيه الكرام بالواقع انا اعتقد بان اذا
ما تابعنا التصريحات الايرانيه قبل الحراك
الثوري الاخير من خلال سته شهور الماضيه
نعلم بان هنالك توجه كامل في ايران كان
يدعو الحكومه الى التوجه الى التخصيب
بنسبه 90% وهو الفريق المسمى فريق سعيد
جليلي لذلك انا اعتقد بان هذا
هذا التوجه هو توجه ايراني بل حتى بمباركه
من خامنا لان
العوامل الاجتماعيه داخليا وحتى الانهيار
الاقتصادي وربما تداوم
العقوبات من الجانب الغربي فيما يبدو جعلت
من هذا الخيار خيارا استراتيجيا للبغاء
على النظام حتى ان الوكاله تقول انه
المخزون يتجاوز السقف المسموح به
في ايران باكثر من ثمانيه عشره مره يعني
هناك ايضا نقطه اخرى في هذا المجال حتى لو
كانت النسب مختلفه ولم تصل الى 90% اضافه
الى انه انتقاد الوكاله لعدم شفافيه ايران
يشي بوضوح بانه كان من المفترض على ايران
ان كان حادثا عارضا ان تبلغ الوكاله بذلك
لكي تبرئ ذمتها ان كانت صادقه
بالفعل يعني نحن نعلم بان خلال ربما منذ
2008 عشر ايران تجاوزت الحد المسموح خاصه
ونحن نعلم بان النسبه المنصوص عليها
باتفاق وخمسه عشر هو ثلاثه فاصل 67 لذلك
هنالك فرق شاسع بين نسبه التخصيب حتى ان
كان 20% او 60% فهو لا يتوافق مع ارتفاع
2005 عشر وهنالك قانون استراتيجيه من
البرلمان هو الذي الزم الحكومه بان لا
تلتزم بتعليمات الوكاله الدوليه الطاقه
الذريه لذلك فيما يبدو بان التوجه
الايراني الان سواء في الحكومه او
البرلمان او حتى المجلس الاعلى للامن
القومي هو كله هو صلاله هذه المرحله كما
اسلفت وهي الى مرحله التخصيب تسعين خاصه
وانه عدد الايام لانتاج قنبله اقل بكثير
كان اشهر والان نتحدث عن ايام وهذا ما
اكده البانتاجون وسنعود اليك بهذا الموضوع
ففي تحذيره من خطوره الموقف قال
البانتاجون ان ايران كانت تحتاج لثني عشر
شهرا لانتاج قنبله نوويه في 2018 والان
تحتاج الى 12 يوما
كان التقدم النووي الايراني منذ خروجنا من
الاتفاق النووي لافتا بالعوده الى عام
2018 عندما قررت الاداره السابقه لانسحاب
من الاتفاق النووي كان من الممكن ان
تستغرق ايران حوالي 12 شهرا لانتاج قنبله
نوويه واحده من المواد الانشطاريه الان
سيستغرق الامر حوالي 12 يوما اعتقد انه من
غير المرجح ان يمارس الروس ضغوطا على
ايران للانضمام الى اي اتفاق دبلوماسي
لانهم يحاولون دفع ايران لشحن المزيد من
الطائرات بدون طيار والصواريخ وغيرها من
القدرات
اعرف نصر البحث في الشان الايراني من لندن
مجددا اذا ماذا يمكن القول تجاه طبيعه
التصدي الغربي لذلك رغم كل التصريحات
عاليه السقف وصلنا الى هذا الحجم من
الخطوره ولا يبدو ان هناك استعداد امريكي
لاعطاء الضوء الاخضر الكامل على الاقل
لاسرائيل ان لم تكن تريد ان تشترك في
عمليه نوعيه بذاتها
يعني انا اعتقد بان الرد فيما يتعلق
بالجانب الاسرائيلي او الجانب الاوروبي
والجانب الامريكي الان لم يعد موحد بمعنى
ان هنالك خطوط حمراء لكل واحده من من هذه
الدول او هذه الاطراف
العتبه النوويه التي كانت تخشاها اسرائيل
عمليا ايران وصلتها لذلك انا اعتقد بان
بالنموذج الاسرائيلي نحن سنشهد تفعيل ما
كان يعرف ربما راس الاخطبوط هذه
الاستراتيجيه سوف تفعل من الجانب
الاسرائيلي بغض النظر حتى من
موقف الجانب الاوروبي او الجانب الامريكي
لان هذا خط احمر اسرائيلي اما الجانب
الاوروبي فانا اعتقد بان هنالك احتماليه
كبيره الان لتفعيل اليه الزناد المنصوب
عليها باتفاق 2015 اما الجانب الامريكي
فاعتقد بان بانه سوف يكون مع الرؤيه التي
يريدها
الجانب الاوروبي ربما هنالك تغارب مع
الرؤيه التي يريدها الجانب الاوروبي وهي
تفعيل اليه الزناد خاصه وان عدم تفعيل
اليه الزناد يحتم على الجانب الاوروبي ان
يختار خيار ربما اكثر مراره وهو تصنيف
الحرس الثوري كمنظمه ارهابيه هنا بين هذين
الخيارين ربما تفعيل اليه الزنات هو
الخيار الاسهل الى الجانب الاوروبي شكرا
جزيلا لك البحث في الشان الايراني يعرف
نصر من لندن تحياتي اليك
[موسيقى]
في الوقت الذي تحتدم فيه المعارك في شرق
اوكرانيا حدد رئيس الوزراء الاوكراني
ملامح النصر لبلاده في مقابله خاصه مع
العربيه ملامحوا لن تكتمل الا بدعم اوروبي
قوي يقطع ما تبقى من مصادر التمويل للاله
العسكريه الروسيه وبخاصه من صناعتها
النوويه وصناعه الماس
نجري حوارا مثمرا للغايه مع شركائنا من
الاتحاد الاوروبي والولايات المتحده
والدول الشركه الاخرى التي تنضم بشان
زياده ضغط العقوبات على روسيا كما نعلم ان
اوروبا تبنت بالفعل احدى عشره حزمه من
العقوبات ونطلب من شركائنا فرض عقوبات على
الصناعه النوويه الروسيه وعلى صناعه تعدين
الماس وايضا عقوبات شخصيه وفرديه على
السياسيين الروس ومديريه تلك الشركات
المتعلقه بتمويل الحرب في اوكرانيا لماذا
تعد العقوبات مهمه من المهم جدا التاكيد
ان العقوبات لا تمنح روسيا فرصه لملء
الميزانيه التي تمول من خلالها العدوان
المسلح
للعربيه ان بلاده تسعى لمحاكمه روسيا عما
وصفه بشرائم الحرب التي ترتكبها متهما
طهران بمساعده موسكو في ارتكاب هذه
الجرائم
نتحدث عن فتح محكمه دوليه ضد العدوان
الروسي ضد السياسيين الروس الذين اصدروا
اوامر جنائيه مماثله نتحدث ايضا عن حقيقه
ان المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه تحقق بالفعل
في جرائم جنائيه وجرائم حرب لروسيا
وتحدثوا عن حقيقه ان ايران حليف او متواطئ
في جرائم الحرب التي ترتكبها روسيا
بالتاكيد في اطار التحقيق الجنائي
بالمحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه كجزء من تحقيق
المحكمه العسكريه الدوليه سنتحدث عن حقيقه
ان ايران ساعدت روسيا في ارتكاب هذه
الجرائم
المقابله اجرتها زميله ليال الاختيار وفي
السياق ذاته قال رئيس
الاوكرانيسكي خلال لقائه المدعي العام
للمحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه كريم خان قال ان
الجرائم التي ارتكبها الروس على اراضي
اوكرانيا يجب ان لا تمر دون عقاب مشددا
على ضروره تقديم المذنبين للعداله
في الاثناء قال امين وعامر حلف شمال
الاطلس انه يجب التاكد من التاريخ من ان
التاريخ لن يعيد نفسه وان بوتين لن يستمر
في مهاجمه جيرانه
الشيء المهم الان هو دعم اوكرانيا وبعد
ذلك لا يمكن لاحد ان يقول بالضبط متى
تنتهي هذه الحرب ولكن عندما تنتهي نحتاج
الى التاكد من ان التاريخ لا يعيد نفسه
وان الرئيس بوتين لا يمكنه الاستمرار في
مهاجمه الجيران وبالتالي نحتاج الى تعزيز
القدرات العسكريه لاوكرانيا ولكن ايضا
ابحث عن طرق تضمن ان الرئيس بوتين لن يغزو
اوكرانيا مره اخرى
هذا وتجددت العقبات فيما يخص الدعم الغربي
لاوكرانيا فقد افادت صحيفه نيويورك تايمز
ان دول اوروبيه تواجه مشكلات في توفير
دبابات التي تعهدت بتقديمها لكيف حيث افاد
مسؤولون غربيون بان توفير دبابات ليوبارد
لاوكرانيا ليس سهلا كالاعلان عنه نيويورك
تايمز نقلت عن مسؤولين المان ان جيوشا
اوروبيه رفضت ارسال ليوباردي اوكرانيا
بسبب حاجتها لها
لكن ماذا عن الوضع الميداني في اوكرانيا
معارك بخموت تحتدم وقوات فاجنر الروسيه
باتت تقاتل داخل بعض احياء المدينه وليس
على اطرافها
هنا في بخمه الاوكرانيه تقترب اطول واشرس
معركه في الحرب من نهايتها حيث تقول
المعلومات والصور القادمه من هناك ان
الخناق يضيق على المقاومين الاوكران ضيق
يقابله اصرار على الصمود حتى النهايه
المدينه الصغيره بحجمها الكبيره في اسمها
وموقعها الاستراتيجي اصبحت ايقونه في
الحرب الدائره منذ عام ورمزيه للانتصار
لمن يسيطر عليها بعد اشهر من الجمود على
طول الجبهات المشتعله شرقا وجنوبا
تعتبر بخموت اخر القلاع الاوكرانيه في
اقليم دونيتسك شرقي اوكرانيا وهدفا رئيسيا
للرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين حيث سيمنح
الاستيلاء عليها موسكو انتصارا نادرا بعد
عده اشهر من النكسات موقع المدينه يشكل
نقطه التقاء استراتيجيه بين منطقتي دونات
تشكلان القلب الصناعي الاوكراني اضافه
لكونها تعتبر نقطه انطلاق جديده للجيش
الروسي باتجاه العمق الاوكراني واكبر
مدينتين في المنطقه هما كراماتورس كواسل
تقول اخر المعلومات ان قوات فاجنر دخلت
احياء باخموت الشرقيه والوسطى فيما تزال
الاحياء الشماليه بيد الجيش الاوكراني
لتتحول المعركه الى حرب شوارع بين الطرفين
لم تنفي صعوبه الوضع في المدينه شبه
المحاصره لكنها تصر وجيشها على الصمود رغم
شراسه المعارك وموقفها المعقد
يمكن للجميع ان يرى اننا نواجه صعوبه في
هذا القسم الامامي العدو يهاجم باستمرار
في مجموعات صغيره وكبيره فاحيانا يواصلون
القذف المدفعي واليوم التالي يشنون هجمات
المشاه انه امر صعب لكن اولادنا يستمرون
في الصمود بارضهم
بين تراقب سقوط وقدره على الصمود فالاكيد
ان القتال في بخموت اصبح معركه كسر عظم
بين الطرفين معركه قد تكون انعطافه جديده
لحرب بدات لتوها عامها الثاني
معنى من كيف موفد العربيه الى هناك احمد
باكاتو اهلا بك معنا احمد بخصوص
تحديدا منطقه استراتيجيه ومهمه جدا الى اي
مدى المعلومات التي لدينا حتى الان واضحه
وحاسمه بخصوص بقاء قوات في المناطق التي
سيطرت عليها ام اننا نشهد معارك كروه فار
هناك
نعم يا طاهر اهلا بك يعني حرب شوارع من
مبنى لمبنى من بيت لبيت ما بين القوات
الاوكرانيه المتواجده في الجهه الغربيه من
بخمه وما بين قوات فاجنر او القوه الاكثر
جهوزيه في في كما تقول القياده العسكريه
هنا تقول ان هذه القوات العسكريه الروسيه
تهاجم بمجموعات كثيره ذات اعداد صغيره
الكثير من المناطق في محاوله منها لتطويق
القوات الاوكرانيه المتواجده في غرب
المدينه بصوره كامله يعني تهاجم القوات
الاوكرانيه من الشمال ومن الشرق ومن
الجنوب بقيت فقط الجهه الغربيه التي يصل
اليها الامداد لقوات الاوكرانيه المتواجده
القياده العسكريه هنا تقول انها ترسل
بصوره مستمره يعني اعداد وافراد ومعدات
اللي هي القوات المتواجده هناك لكنها لا
تنكر تراجع عن تصفه بالتكتيكي والظرف تحت
وطاه الهجمات القويه من القوات فاجنر
المدعومه بالطائ الحربيه والطائرات
المسيره والمدفعيه بالطبع بخمت بتت عقبه
بصوره كبيره امام القوات الروسيه التي
ربما حتى ان بخم اكتسبت شهرتها من انها
بتت عصيه وظلت عصيه بصوره كبيره على
القوات الروسيه لكنها ليست بذات الاهميه
الكبيره نظرا
للمستوى الحديث عنها في الاعلام وفي
الوسائل الاعلام المختلفه لكن بصفه عامه
يمكن القول ان القياده العسكريه هنا تقول
انها باقيه في بخمه لم تنتهي المعركه
المعركه مستمره وربما مع اقتراب الربيع
سيصعب على قوات الروسيه التقدم لان الارض
تتحول من صلبه الى موحده او طينيه يصعب
على ذلك تقدم القوات الروسيه في هذه الارض
ايضا لم تقف الامور عند باخمت وانما ايضا
هناك قصف لبعض المناطق القريبه كوبي كوبي
القريبه او شرق خرقيف ايضا هناك محاولات
للتقدم بعد بخمه الاستوديو كذلك روماتوسك
لذلك بخمت هي معركه هامه في خرسون ايضا
كان هناك قصف صاروخي من جانب قوات الروسيه
ما اسفر عن تدمير مبنى وتوفي شخصين واصيب
اخرين ذابروجيا ايضا تقول القوات
الاوكرانيه انه كان هناك قصف في هذه
المدينه وهناك تضيق بصوره مستمره على
السكان الذين يعانون بصوره مستمره لتقييد
ايصال التدفئه والمياه الساخنه اليهم
وكذلك بعد ان تم تسريح العاملين في المحطه
النوويه بصوره كامله هناك تعيين لعمال
روسيا يعني لا يملكون الكفاءه الكفاءه
الكامله للتعامل مع هذه
المحطه النوويه الشيء الاخير فيما يتعلق
بالمبادره الصينيه طاهر سريعا يعني رئيس
مكتب الرئيس الاوكرانيا يتحدث ان المبادره
الصينيه بها الكثير من نقاط الضعف خاصه
فيما يتعلق باطلاق وقف اطلاق النار هو
يقول ان هذا الامر يستغله الروس في اعاده
بناء تحصيلاتهم وتجميد الوضع من ثم
الاستعداد لضمه اراضي جديده من اراضي
الاوكرانيه لذلك الامر غير مرحب به على
الاطلاق بها الكثير من نقاط الضعف التي
تستفيد منها الروس نعم شكرا جزيلا احمد
مفرد العربيه على كل هذه المعلومات تحياتي
اليك
[موسيقى]
واضمن التحركات المرتبطه بالحرب في
اوكرانيا دبلوماسيه الامريكيه تصل الى
اسيا الوسطى في محاوله لسحب جمهوريات
المنطقه من فلك روسيا والصين وزير
الخارجيه وصل الى كازاخستان في زيارته
الاولى منذ توليه منصبه وهو معتبر مسعا
امريكيا لتوسيع نفوذ واشنطن في المنطقه
ومنع روسيا من الالتفاف على العقوبات
الدوليه المفروضه عليها
قمه جمهوريات اسيا الوسطى والولايات
المتحده او ما يطلق عليها مجموعه سيخ 5 +
1 والتي تضم كلا من الدوله المضيفه
كازاخستان
وتركمانستان واوزباكستان افتتح وزير
الخارجيه انطوني بلينكن زيارته بالاجتماع
مع نظيره الكازخي مختار في العاصمه استنى
قبل التوجه الى القصر الرئاسي للقاء
الرئيس قاسم جو مارت توكايييف
[موسيقى]
اغتنم هذه الفرصه للاعراب عن تقديرنا
للدعم المستمر والثابت من الولايات
المتحده لاستقلالنا وسلامه اراضينا
وسيادتنا
من جانبه اشاد وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
بعمق العلاقات بين واشنطن واستنى مشيرا
الى ان بلاده ستستمر في الدفع باتجاه
تقويه العلاقه بين الدولتين
[موسيقى]
من المهم بالطبع على المستوى الثنائي
البناء على العمل الرائع الذي انجز على
مدى اكثر من 30 عاما لتعميق وتقويه
شراكتنا واعتقد اننا في العامين الماضيين
اكدنا اهميه هذه العلاقه القويه والتي
ستزداد قوه ونحن ملتزمون بذلك
القمه الاقليميه تاتي على خلفيه الذكرى
السنويه للحرب الروسيه في اوكرانيا والتي
واجهت ضربه للاقتصاد في جميع انحاء العالم
وفي وقت تتطلع فيه دول اسيا الوسطى لتخفيف
اعتمادها على موسكو في التجاره والامن
وغير ذلك ومع استمرار الحرب في اوكرانيا
اعتمد قاده دول اسيا الوسطى موقفا متوازنا
من النزاع مع البقاء على حذر كبير بسبب
الاتفاقيات الرسميه مع موسكو والوزن
الاقتصادي والامني لروسيا الجمهوريه
السوفيتيه السابقه الخمس كانت امتنعت او
لم تشارك في التصويت الذي جرى الخميس
الماضي في الجمعيه العموميه للامم المتحده
على مشروع قانون يطلب من القوات الروسيه
مغادره اوكرانيا رغم الحديث عن الابتعاد
عن روسيا الا ان دول اسيا الوسطى لم تنفصل
تماما عن موسكو مع استمرار بعض الدول في
السماح بنقل البضائع الخاضعه للعقوبات الى
روسيا حتى وان انتقدت علنا السياسات
الروسيه
على الطرف الاخر وعدد كازاخستان بزياده
صادرات النفط الى اوروبا عبر الطرق التي
لا تمر عبر روسيا خاصه وان الاخيره اغلقت
مرتين في الاشهر القليله الماضيه خط
انابيب بحر قزوين الذي ينقل ما يقرب من
ثمانين في المئه من صادرات كازاخستان
النفطيه عبر روسيا الى البحر الاسود ومع
توقع تراجع نفوذ موسكو بدا الدول الاخرى
تحاول ايجاد مكان لها في المنطقه الغنيه
بمصادر الطاقه والموارد المعدنيه الهائله
الصين من هذه الدول ونذكر ان الزياره
الخارجيه الاولى للرئيس للخارج منذ بدء
جائحه كوفيد كانت الى كازاخستان
واوزباكستان ايضا تحظى تركيا بتقارب اكبر
مع دول المنطقه الناطقه جميعها بالتركيه
ما عدا تاجكستان وعلى الاراضي التركيه
التقوا رؤساء من دول المنطقه بالرئيس رجب
طيب اردوغان خلال الاشهر الماضيه لعقد
صفقات مع انقره لشراء اسلحه وطائرات
بيرقدار المسيره كما وقعت كازاخستان صفقه
لانتاج طائرات عسكريه تركيه دون طيار في
كازاخستان
[موسيقى]
اذا موسكو تقول ان بعض اعضاء مجلس الامن
يخدمون المسلحين الذين يعرقلون ايصال
المساعدات لسوريا نتابع في موضوعنا السابق
من غريبه الاستاذ في العلاقات الدوليه
اهلا بك دكتور الى اي مدى باعتقادك يمكن
لواشنطن ان تستمر في الضغط على هذه الدول
تحديدا في اسيا الوسطى للابقاء على
سياستها التي تحاول امساك العصا من
المنتصف مع روسيا
فعلا هذه الدول تحاول وهذا ما اشار اليه
اليوم في
الاحاطه الاعلاميه لكل من الوزيرين
الخارجيه وسيرين
والولايات المتحده حيث قال ان بلاده
والمجموعه هذه الدول في اسيا الوسطى تريد
الحفاظ على علاقه متوازنه مع جميع الاطراف
والحفاظ على مصالحها ايضا وفي نفس الوقت
الذي شكر الولايات المتحده وعلى دعمها
وعلى التعاون الاقتصادي وقال بان بلاده
تحاول الالتزام مثلا بالعقوبات ضد روسيا
ولكن في نفس الوقت ايضا قال نقطه مثيره
ومهمه جدا وهي ان بلاده هي جزء من مجموعه
دول الكومن مجموعه الاتحاد الاوروس
الاوراسي وبالتالي فهي حليفه لروسيا ايوه
وهذه كانت مثيره لان هذا كان اخر سؤال اخر
واخر تعليق له على الاقل علنه خلال
الاقاطه الاعلاميه حيث ركز في على ان هناك
فعلا مصالح وعندما سئل اذا كان يخشى روسيا
او ان روسيا تهدد امن بلاده قال انه لا
توجد اي مخاوف وان موضوع الحدود الذي
تحدثت عنه الاداره الامريكيه في الاونه
الاخيره وان لروسيا طموحات في اراضي
كازاخستان قال انه تم تحديد الحدود بنسبه
سبت 70% وهذه حدوث طويله جدا وبالتالي ما
ابرز الملفات التي تعتقد انها ستكون
عقبه امام
انخراط هذه الدول مع الولايات المتحده في
المواجهه ما السقف الذي يمكن ان تصل اليه
بحكم موقعها الجغرافي والتاريخي قبل اي
شيء اخر
هذه الدول سيكون لديها قيود الى حد ما
بعضها داخليه وبعضها ايضا لانها تعلم ان
تعيش ما بين الصين وبين روسيا وهذين
البلدين لديهم خلافات عميقه واشنطن
وبالتالي فانهما يريدان الحفاظ على
علاقاتهما مع دول الجوار وخاصه دول كبرى
ودول مهمه ولكنهما في نفس الوقت يحاولان
تحاول هذه الدول ايضا القول للولايات
المتحده بانها
الحفاظ على علاقه جيده معها وانها تريد
منها ان تقوم بعمليات استثمار في هذه
الدول وايضا في تنويع الاعتماد على الطاقه
اي انها تريد ان تبيع الطاقه لدول صديقه
قد تكون صديقه وحليفه
ولكن في نفس الوقت فان هذه الدول تعلم بان
هناك حدود وانها يجب ان تاخذ ايضا مصالح
الدول التي لها علاقات وثيقه مع هناك
مشكله اخرى ستعاني منها وك انتقادات ان
العقوبات من بعض الصحفيين الذين شاركوا في
الاسئله من تلك الدول بانهم قالوا بان
العقوبات تلحق الضرر باقتصاد بلادهم
وبالتالي فان هذه ايضا احدى المشاكل لان
الاتفاقيات القائمه بين هذه الدول وبين
روسيا وبين الصين تجعل من الصعب جدا
او تطبيق العقوبات الثانويه عليها لان
هناك علاقات اقتصاديه قويه وتجاره بين هذه
الدول بالاضافه والنقطه الاخيره هي ان
هناك عدد كبير من الروس ايضا الذين يعيشون
شكرا جزيلا دكتور غريب الاستاذ في
العلاقات الدوليه من واشنطن على هذه
القراءه تحياتي اليك
في مقابله خاصه مع العربيه قال نائب رئيس
البرلمان الاوكراني ان وثيقه السلام التي
اعلن عنها الرئيس لينسكي بسيطه وواضحه
تتضمن انسحاب روسيا من اراضي اوكرانيا
بشكل كامل وعوده حدودها الى ما قبل عام
واحد وتسعين
وثيقه السلام التي اعلن عنها الرئيس
زلينسكي اقرت في قمه مجموعه دول العشرين
نحن في اوكرانيا نرى انها قمه التسعه عشره
دوله لان روسيا لا تستحق ان تكون بينها
وثيقه السلام بسيطه وتستند الى مبادئ
واضحه مثلا انسحاب روسيا من اراضينا وعوده
قواتها الى موسكو من دون باس والقرم ايضا
وعوده حدودنا الى ما قبل
1991 موقف اوكرانيا واضح وقوي ويدعمه
الاوكرانيون نحن واضحون لا نريد اي تسويه
مع روسيا على حساب سيادتنا بعد كل ما
عانيناه من ويلات الحرب ومختلف الاسلحه
التي استخدمتها رو سيا لتدمير بلدنا
وفيما يتعلق بمبادره الصين للحل في
اوكرانيا انتقد وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه
المبادره قائلا لا يمكنها ان تدعم موسكو
ثم تقدم مقترح سلام في الوقت ذاته
لا يمكن للصين ان تربح من الوجهين حينما
نتحدث عن العدوان الروسي على اوكرانيا لا
يمكن ان تقدم مقترح سلام بيد بينما تغذي
شراره العدوان الذي بدات روسيا بهذه
الاخرى لذا اتمنى ان تاخذ الصين ما نقوله
بجديه وما تقوله الدول الاخرى حول العالم
وان تبتعد عن اي دعم لروسيا
والى بكين وصل الرئيس البيلاروسيه الكسنكو
في زياره تستغرق ثلاثه ايام وتشمل مباحثات
مع الرئيس الصيني وذكرت وكاله بلتا
الرسميه البيلاروسيه ان زياره لوكاتشينكو
للصين جاءت بعد نشر بكينا وثيقه تتضمن
موقفها من النزاع في اوكرانيا
في العربيه 360 ايضا القوه البيضاء تحذر
وفاتان ومئات الاصابات بالكوليرا شمال غرب
سوريا بعد الزلزال
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد اعتبرت انا لينا وزيره
الخارجيه الالمانيه ان حل الدولتين هو
الحل الوحيد لنزع التوتر بين الاسرائيليين
والفلسطينيين وطالبت اسرائيل بالتوقف عن
الاجراءات الاحديه
انا مقتنعه بان من المصلحه الامنيه
الاسرائيل ان يعيش الشباب في غزه والضفه
الغربيه بكرامه ويرون افاق مستقبل جديد
وحتى اذا اعتقد البعض ان هذه فكره عفا
عليها الزمن فنحن نرى ان حل الدولتين هو
الحل الذي يمكن ان يوفر اكبر قدر من الامن
نحن لسنا ساذجين في هذا هذا الحل لن يكون
قريبا لكننا مقتنعون بشده ان هذا الباب
يجب ان يبقى مفتوحا على الاقل ولا تتم
اعاقته بخطوات احاديه الجانب مثل استمرار
بناء المستوطنات
[موسيقى]
قال الرئيس العراقي عبد اللطيف رشيد ان
بلاده تدعم عوده سوريا الى الجامعه
العربيه جاء ذلك خلال لقائه وزير الدوله
البريطانيه لشؤون الشرق الاوسط وشمال
افريقيا طارق احمد واكد رشيد ان بغداد
تتمتع بعلاقات جيده وبناء مع دول الجوار
وفي سوريا اعلنت القوات البيضاء وفاه
شخصين في تفشن للكوليرا في اعقاب كارثه
الزلزال شمال غرب البلاد واوضحت الخوات
البيضاء ان هناك 500
مصابا بالكوليرا جراء دمار البنيه التحتيه
وخطوط المياه والصرف الصحي
وفيما يتعلق بكارثه الزلزال قال المبعوث
الاممي لسوريا انه طالب بعدم تسييس
المساعدات الانسانيه وازاله العراقيل
لانقاذ السوريين المتضررين
[موسيقى]
للاستجابه الانسانيه حثيت الجميع على عدم
تسييس الاستجابه الانسانيه هذا يعني
الوصول هذا ليس الوقت للعب لعبه السياسه
في ليس على المساعده العابره للخطوط
والعابره للحدود هذا يعني توفير الموارد
التبرع بسرعه وبكرر لسوريا للتخلص من
الجميل على العراقيل التي تعيق وصول
الاغاثه للسوريين في المناطق المتاثره
وهذا يعني الهدوء ايضا هذا ليس وقت اتخاذ
التدابير عسكريه او عنيفه
وفي مقابله خاصه مع العربيه اكد فيتال
نعوم كان مستشار المبعوث الامميه لسوريا
اكد امكانيه عقد قمه سوريه التركيه معتبرا
ان الرفض من عدمه بيد السلطات السوريه
وحدها
[موسيقى]
تظن انه على السوريين الاجابه على هذا
السؤال ان كانت لديهم شروط مسبقه ام لا
لعقد قمه سوريه تركيه ما نسمعه من السلطات
السوريه هو انتقادهم للوجود التركي في
شمال سوريا لذلك اعتقد انهم حتى ان بداوا
اي نوع من المحادثات دون شروط مسبقه اعتقد
ان هذا ممكن ويوجد عبر التاريخ كثير من
هذه الامثله وان كان هذا نتيجه لمحادثات
او بشكل مبدئي فسوريا استعادت بكل الاحوال
سيطرتها على كل اراضيها والجانب التركي
يقول ان وجود قواته هو اجراء مؤقت وهم
يؤيدون سياده سوريا على كل اراضيها انا لا
اعتقد ان هذا سيكون شرطا مبدئيا او نتيجه
مباحثات ولكن هذا الشيء ومن وجهه نظ ر
سوريا يجب ان يحدث
وفي تركيا تتفاعل الازمه بشكل مختلف رئيس
حزب الشعب الجمهوري التركي المعارض كمال
كليتش دار اوغلو اتهم السلطات التركيه
بالفشل الذريع في التعامل مع كارثه
الزلزال قائلا ان مؤسسه الهلال الاحمر
التركيه تبيع الخيام للمتضررين من الزلزال
وهو الامر الذي وصفه بالفضيحه كما طالب
اوغلو بتاسيس محاكم جديده تسمى بمحاكم
الزلازل لمن تثبت ادانتهم في انهيار
المباني حتى لا تضيع القضايا في اروقه
المحاكم على حد قوله
المدير العام لمنظمه الصحه العالميه تدرس
ادهان قال ان المنظمه ستدعم انقره في
استجابتها للزلازل خلال جوله له بمخيماتها
الطعيم
[موسيقى]
ناقشنا مع الوزير بعض التحديات التي نراها
الان في المخيمات التي قمنا بزيارتها التي
تتمثل في التهابات الجهاز التنفسي
والتهابات الجهاز الهضمي ومشكله الصحه
العقليه لان الكثير من الناس يعانون
بالفعل من الصدمات والاشخاص الذين يحتاجون
الى خدمات اعاده تقويم العظام ومن جانب
منظمه الصحه العالميه سندعم بكل الوسائل
الممكنه حل المشكلات التي تمت ملاحظتها او
توثيقها
لكن ماذا عن الوضع الاقتصادي في المناطق
التي ضربها الزلزال في تركيا كاميرا
العربيه رصدت الوضع هناك مع الزميل عبد
القادر خربوش
وسط كهرمان مرعش يحاول فاروق استرجاع ما
امكنه من سلع كان يعرضها في محله الذي
حوله الزلزال الى ركام
هذا الشارع كان تجاريا بامتياز وكنت امتلك
محلا لبيع السجاد من اربعه طوابق لكن
الزلزاله قضى على كل شيء ولا اعلم كيف
ومتى ساعود لعمل مجددا
الكارثه التي اودت بحياه عشرات الالاف
خلفت كذلك ركودا اقتصاديا في الولايات
الجنوبيه للبلاد وحولت مواطنيها الناجين
الى حياه البطاله والعيش على المساعدات
حاليا اصبحت عاطلا عن العمل كما تشاهد
السوق وكل المحلات اصبحت ركاما حتى وان
اردت العوده الى تجاره فلن استطيع لاني لم
اعد املك شيئا
الزلزال ومثل ما دمر اليابسه وما عليها في
الجنوب التركي لحقت اضراره البحر كذلك
ومست الميناء حسب اقتصاد المنطقه ومصدر
قوت اهاليها ميناء اسكندرون بهاتاي لحقته
اضرار زلزال واوقفت نشاط صياديه
نفس الشكل كلهم كسر كله ما بنعرف كيف بدنا
نعمل شو بدو يصير فينا تقرير للبنك الدولي
قدر اضرار الزلزال باربعه مليار دولار
فيما يرجح اقتصاديون تجاوز هذا الرقم
بكثير اما السلطات التركيه فدخلت في سباق
مع الزمن لاحتواء الازمه والتبعاتها عبد
القادر خربوش العربيه جنوب تركيا
[موسيقى]
ملف اشباه الموصلات يعود مجددا للواجهه في
الولايات المتحده التي تعتبره جزءا من
امنها القومي اداره الرئيس جو بايدن تعتمد
خطه جديده لتعزيز سلطه الحكومه الفيدراليه
على هذا القطاع الخطه تقضي بان مصنعي
اشباه الموصلات في الولايات المتحده
والذين يسعون للحصول على شريحه تقارب
اربعين مليار دولار من الاعانات الحكوميه
سيحتاجون الى توفير ظروف افضل لعمالهم
اضافه لمشاركه بعض الارباح الزائده مع
الحكومه وزيره التجاره الامريكيه جينا
ريموند قالت ان القواعد الماليه ستشجع
الشركات على طلب التمويل الذي تحتاجه فقط
وسيمنعها من تحويل اموال دافعي الضرائب
لملئ جيوب مساهمها الاداره الامريكيه كانت
اقرت العام الماضي قانون اشباه الموصلات
الذي خص 52 مليار دولار لتوسيع تصنيع
وابحاث اشباه الموصلات في امريكا على امل
جعل البلاد اقل اعتمادا على الموردين
الاجانب للرقائق الالكترونيه في وقت لاحق
اغرى احتمال الوصول الى هذه الاموال صانعي
الرقائق المحليين والاجانب للاعلان عن خطط
او البدء في انشاء مشاريع جديده في
اريزونا وتكساس اوهايو ونيويورك وولايات
اخرى كما ذكرنا اداره بايدن تتعاطى مع
اشباه الموصلات ضمن نطاق مفهوم الامن
القومي سواء من الناحيه العسكريه او تلك
المدنيه ايضا وبالفعل يعتبر الرئيس الحالي
اكثر اهتماما بهذا الجانب من اسلافهم
[موسيقى]
الولايات المتحده تواجه معضله تكمن في
تخلفها النسبي على الصعيد العالمي في هذا
المجال في وقت يزداد فيه الطلب على
الرقائق بينما الانتاج لا يوازيه على
الاطلاق نيويورك تايمز نشرت تقريرا حول
مصنع تي اس ام سي التايواني اكبر منتج
لاشباه الموصلات في العالم واشارت الى
شكوك الموظفين بشان استثمار الشركه هذا
مبنى
لبناء مصنع بمبلغ اربعين مليار دولار في
ولايه اريزونا الامريكيه الصحيفه اجرت
مقابلات مع احد عشر من موظفي الشركه
وقالوا ان المشروع الجديد يمكن ان يصرف
الانتباه عن التركيز على البحث والتطوير
اشار الموظفون الى ان البناء في الولايات
المتحده مكلف باربعه اضعاف التكلفه في
تايوان مدفوعا بنفقات العماله والتصاريح
ما قد يضر بربحيه الشركه هذا العام
كما تحدث البعض عن القلق بشان كيفيه دمج
مصنع اريزونا بين الموظفين الامريكيين
والتايوانيين لصعوبه توحيد الممارسات بين
الموظفين في الدولتين او من الدولتين
والتوقعات بان العمال التايوانيين
سيتحملون مسؤوليات اكبر من زملائهم
الامريكيين
[موسيقى]
من جانبها تحدثت عن هجره الرقائق الدقيقه
واشباه الموصلات من الصين الى روسيا رغم
العقوبات الصحيفه قالت ان وقفه تدفق اشباه
الموصيلات الى روسيا يمثل مشكله صعبه بشكل
خاص احد الاسباب الرئيسه هو ان الصين التي
رفضت الانضمام الى العقوبات الغربيه على
روسيا تقع في قلب تجاره الرقائق العالميه
فضلا عن كونها مصنعا مهما للرقائق منخفضه
الجوده والسعر واظهرت البيانات العامه
استمرار التدفق الى روسيا مباشره من الصين
ما انعش واردات روسيا من اشباه الموصلات
بقوه لتقترب من متوسطها الشهري قبل حرب
اوكرانيا اضافه للصين ارتفعت الصادرات
التركيه من اشباه الموصلات المماثله الى
روسيا من 79 الف دولار عام 2021 الى ثلاثه
ملايين ومائتين الف دولار العام الماضي
لتصبح تركيا التي رفضت دعم العقوبات
الدوليه على روسيا مصدرا رئيسا لهذه
السلعه الى موسكو
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا من دكتور احمد بنافع والسادسه
وامن الشبكات في جامعه سانهو الحكوميه
اهلا بك معنا
يعتبر ذلك مساله امن قومي لنحاول ان نفسر
للمشاهدين اكثر لماذا
اكثر من اسلافه ايضا
كثير من المنتجات اللي حوالينا واللي
بنستخدمها بتستخدم اشباه الموصلات يعني
الاحصائيه اللي اصدرتها
50 مليار جهاز موصل للانترنت في 2020
وحيصل الى 57 مليار الجهاز في 25 وكلها
تحتاج اشباح الموصلات واللي شفناه احنا
خلال الكوفيد وكيف انه سلسله الموردين
يعني تاثرت فيها والشركات السيارات ما
قدرت انها تنتج بسبب العجز في اشباه
الموصلات
اذا هذا سبب اساسي ولكن الى اي مدى تعتقد
انه دعم اللي اعطته الحكومه سيكون كافيا
للتعويض
الدعوه 52 مليار مثل ما ذكر التقرير يعني
هو كبير جدا من ناحيه انه بيساعدهم يبتدوا
في المشاريع يعني مثلا المشروع اللي في
اريزونا اللي بتقوم بالشركه تايوانيه
بدا ب 12 مليار وبعدين ارتفع الى 40 مليار
شركه ابل ساعدت في انها تحصل على دعم
للشركه التايونيه عشان يفتحوا المصنع هناك
هم يعني ما حيتبنوا الصناعه بقدم انهم
يساعدوهم يفتحوا مصانع كثيره في امريكا
طيب بخصوص الصين وروسيا كيف بالمقابل
ستتعامل الولايات المتحده مع تصنيعهم هم
فيما يتعلق بالداخل الصيني او توريد ذلك
لروسيا من الصين ومن تركيا ومن جهه اخرى
السوق مفتوح الان يعني كاحصائيه ثلاث دول
تتحكم في 88% من صناعه اشباه المواصلات
اللي هي تايوان والصين وكوريا الجنوبيه
فالصين هي لما نقلت التكنولوجيا هذا الى
روسيا نقلت التكنولوجيا لانها تعرف ان في
عندهم امكانيات وعندهم كمان الموارد
الطبيعيه اللي ممكن يستغلوها في اشباه
المواصلات نفس اللي حصل في في تركيا
فالسوق مفتوحه للكل ولكن نحن سنشهد حربا
من نوع اخر في هذا الاطار بين هذه الدول
على الاقل
هذا وارد جدا لانه تتكلم انت على مليارات
من الاجهزه اللي بتتصل بالانترنت اللي
تحتاج اشباه المواصلات السيارات الجديده
كلها فيها اشباه موصلات الاسلحه فيها
اشباح مواصلات فكون انه اي بلد تتحكم في
نسبه اكبر او تزيد نسبتها هذه حتكون عندك
اكتفاء ذاتي في الصوره هذه فهذه فعلا
حتكون وارده انا حتكون حرب من ناحيه
الاشباه الموصلات ومن يمتلكها ولكن
الولايات المتحده يعني قادره في هذا
المجال ايضا ان تحسد اكثر في العالم اذا
ما قصنا على ملفات اخرى اليس كذلك نعم
صحيح هي من ناحيه المال ومن ناحيه النفود
هم بحاول الان انه يجلبوا كثير من الشركات
انها تفتح مصانع داخليه هنا في في امريكا
يعني قائمه طويله جدا من سامسونج يعني
زارهم الرئيس على اساس انه يعني يسوي
اتفاقيه معاهم انهم يفتحوا مصنع ثاني هنا
في امريكا فهذه هي القضيه انه فاهمين انه
الحرب القادمه الالكترونيه بس بشق التقني
من الموضوع ليش تايوان دائما يعني هي
سباقه ورائده في هذا المجال
خاصه في الرقائق الادق والاصغر من غيرها
حتى في التقرير الذي ذكرناه نتحدث عن انه
في خشيه من انه يكون العمال التايوانيين
يقومون باغلب العمل مقابل زملائهم
الامريكيين لماذا كلام سليم يا اخ طاهر في
مشاكل حاصله في المصنع يعني حتى قبل ما
يؤدي المصنع يعني اخذوا 400 مهندس امريكي
الى الى تايوان يدربوهم على عمليه التصنيع
المشكله اللي اللي في مصانع زي هذه انك
تشتغل 24 ساعه ما توقف ما في مجال لانها
توقفها في ورديات
والان اللي وجدوا انه المهندس بيشتغل 12
ساعه كمعدل فهذا مع الامريكان ما حيمشي
حتكون في مشاكل من ناحيه الاداره ويعني
ومن ناحيه طبيعه العمل هذا هو سبب المشاكل
لانهم خايفين انه انه تحصل يعني في
الناحيه هذه منى معتمدوا على الموظفين
التايونين اكثر من الامريكان فهذا هو
السبب الخشيه اللي هون فيها الان شكرا
جزيلا لك
استاذ الهندسه وامن الشبكات في جامعه
الحكوميه تحياتي اليك
اذا مشاهدينا الكرام اللجنه الروسيه تبدا
التحقيق في توريد مواد كيميائيه سامه الى
كرامه
اجانب اخر الاخبار العاجله وحاكم
4000 شخص غادروا المنطقه الحدوديه جراء
القصف الاوكراني تتابعون معنا في العربيه
360 ايضا بعد الفاصل دفعوا ثمانيه الاف
يورو من اجل رحله الامل فاتضح انها كانت
رحله الموت
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد حاولت شبكه سي ان بي سي
اللجوء الى تشات جي بي تي لتنظيم رحله سفر
جاءت النتيجه انه لا يمكن التعويل بشكل
كامل على الاجوبه التي يعطيها التطبيق هذا
فضلا عن اعترافه بانه تطبيق ذكاء اصطناعي
وليس لديه تفضيلات شخصيه كي يوصي بها
ويقدمها دون غيرها
روبوت دردشه الذكاء الاصطناعي او كما يسمى
تشات جي بي تي يكتب النثر والشعر والنصوص
البرمجيه باختصار انه يبدو كانسان يعترف
حتى باخطائه شبكه سي ان بي سي جربت
التطبيق على طريقتها لاختبار مدى دقه
المعلومات التي يقدمها حيث حاولت طلب
تنظيم رحله سفر فرد عليها بانها فكره
رائعه ثم رشح لها عده دول بناء على
تفضيلاتها لكن في ختام المحادثه خلصت
تقرير الى انه لا يمكن التعويل بشكل كامل
على الاجوبه التي يعطيها التطبيق فالخطا
الفادح وقع حينما قدم توصيه بفندق
على انه في بالي لكنه في الحقيقه يقع في
كندا
اما تذاكر السفر فلا يمكن لتطبيق الذكاء
الاصطناعي تقديم معلومات عن الرحله
الحاليه او المساعده في حجزها او تحديد
اسعارها فقط يقدم اسماء شركات الطيران
وحتى حينما سئل الروبوت عن رايه في افضل
شركه طيران اكتفى بالاجابه انه ليس لديه
تفضيلات او اراء شخصيه وفوق ذلك اشار الى
افضل خمس شركات طيران حسب سكاي تراكس خلال
العام 20 21 الا ان القائمه وفق سي ان بي
سي تعود للعام 2019
وبشكل او باخر فان الروبوت قد وقع هذه
المره في حفرته فبعد ان حاول ان يهدد
العالم بالرموز النوويه وبهندسه وباء يفتك
بالعالم وانه يحلم بان يصبح انسانا ها هو
بحروفه يؤكد انه مجرد تطبيق ذكاء اصطناعي
في تصريح اليوم في العربيه 360 كنا شفافين
ومنفتحين وشاركنا كل البيانات عن اصل
الفيروس التصريح هو للمتحدث باسم الخارجيه
الصينيه ماونينج ماو التي اكدت ايضا ان
محاولات تاسيس لقضيه لن تضر بالصين وانما
بمصداقيه الولايات المتحده وياتي هذا
التصريح بعد تقرير قدمته وزاره الطاقه
الامريكيه خلص الى ان الفيروس تسرب عن من
احد المختبرات الصينيه دون عمد لكن البيت
الابيض لم يتبندا
فيديو اليوم هو فيديو الايام والشهور
والسنوات الماضيه في العراق في الحقيقه
بلاد الرافدين عطشان انهارها تجف وحتى
الان لا تفاهم مع بنات السدود في جوارها
تركيا وايران
صوره اليوم في العربيه 360 من شواطئ جنوب
ايطاليا هذا كل ما تبقى من حلم العشرات في
العبور الى اوروبا بدات الرحله من ازمير
التركيه وانتهت بماساه على صخره في
الايطاليه انتهت بعد ان دفع كل مهاجر
ثمانيه الاف يورو في رحله الموت
نكتفي بهذا القدر ونتابع في اخبار الساعه
مع صهيب شراير الان صهيب نزل لديك مساء
الخير لدينا بدايه موسم اعياد العربيه كما
نتابع من خلال المظاهر التي بدات تظهر
الهاشتاج العربيه يعيشون عاما طبعا
البانس وكذلك الاقداح ولدينا ايضا
البطاقات كذلك تغيرت وصولا الى ثلاثه
ثلاثه كل عام وانت بخير بالف خير صهيب
الكلمه لك شكرا جزيلا
[موسيقى]